I'm joined today by Bill pres he's
hosted the bill press show author of the
new book from the left a life in the
crossfire bill the book is super
interesting I think a lot of people
might be surprised or at least if not
surprised interested in your upbringing
I mean your early life was won pretty
heavily steeped in the Catholic Church
right I think a lot of people probably
don't know that how was your family
Catholic growing up my family was
Catholic my mother was a Protestant but
my father was Catherine my grandmother
was a Catholic and you know one of the
rules in those days was you're married
and I'm Catholic
the kids still had to be raised ethics
and so we were I mean church every
Sunday altar boy Catholic boys high
school and that was very very much a
part of our family so much so that when
I graduated from high school I even
thought at the time I had a vocation for
the priesthood and I I joined the
seminary and spent a solid 10 years of
my life studying for the priesthood and
you I mean not only was your family not
only were you raised Catholic but your
family was was pretty conservative how
did your politics end up so different
you know you're right I grew up it was a
small town in Delaware Delaware City all
of my family were Republicans I if I had
stayed there I think I'd be a trump
voter today right god forbid but I
always say I became a Democrat because
my parents were Republicans I think I
sort of rebelled even at that time
against what I was supposed to think and
how I was supposed to act but I I also
very early on sort of got the sense that
which I still believe that the
Democratic Party was the party
that was on the side of the little guy
in the middle class and not the
Republican Party and as you moved away
politically from where your family was
but
do you still consider yourself Catholic
religious or did that change as well
politically a long way and I'm sure
we'll get more into that no I would
still say first of all III don't go to I
don't go to church anymore I find
organized religion not part of my life
and even skeptical about any organized
religion I still think I maintain a
basic set of faith values from those
days that I try to live by and I try to
make decisions following I'm the great
Tim Russert once called me a sermon on
the mount Catholic and I kind of wire
that wear that as a badge of honor so I
try to live up to those principles but
to me that doesn't include the necessity
of showing up every Sunday morning in a
Catholic Church
what anything come sort of in total
Americans have been moving away from not
only religion as sort of church
membership but also from religious
belief what do you think is driving that
well I think a certain amount of it is
materialism frankly it is consumerism
there is that I also think it's more and
more and certainly in my case that
people find organized religion or the
path that they're delivered on a regular
basis on a Sunday in sermons or some of
the dictates of organized religion to be
not relevant anymore
not helpful and maybe even contradictory
particularly I think that's true of
Millennials huh that's reasoning so I
mean you would you say that consumerism
is more responsible for pulling people
out or pushing them out of religion more
so than something like scientific
knowledge is advanced the advance of
scientific knowledge I should have added
scientific knowledge as part of that I
guess maybe I didn't because I just kind
of take it for granted
but you're definitely right in there you
know for some people it's that
skepticism or refusal to accept science
that has kept them in there particularly
evangelicals right in in their lockstep
version of Christianity I think those
are those are all factors and I think
particularly when young people today you
know they hear somebody say oh you know
transgender is wrong or LGBTQ is wrong
right or a woman has no control of her
own body I mean they just they're just
not willing to accept that the way
people once did from that authority
figure that happened to be standing in
the pulpit let's talk a little bit about
the 2016 election and what's going on
now you supported Bernie Sanders for the
nomination in 2016 as did I you also at
one point were the chair of the
California Democratic Party so you have
maybe different view of how the DNC the
National DNC behaved during 2016 give me
your assessment I mean what do you think
of how the DNC managed the primary in
2016 I think it was shameful the way
they managed the primary in 2016 by the
way I thought I I was chair of the
California Democratic Party David for
three years from 93 to 96 yep
and so that was some time ago but even
at that time I I fought the DNC I again
from California I just thought it was
Washington trying to dictate everything
a cookie cutter approach in every state
I really thought the fact that Iowa and
New Hampshire were first in every every
year you know every four years when what
they really do not represent the
American people so little diversity and
so I was always sort of a never trusted
the DNC but particularly in the 2016
campaign I think their behavior they
were owned lock stock and barrel by the
Clinton campaign it was a
very very unfair to Bernie Sanders or
anybody else who was trying to contest
the nomination
the DNC had a deal with Hillary where
they were in the primary when they
should have been totally neutral and let
me back up as state chair of California
you're in one of our rules was we never
took a position in the primary right we
let the Democrats Democratic voters
decide who their candidate was going to
be in 2016 the DNC decided they were
going to coronate Hillary they made a
deal with her without anybody else's
knowledge to raise money during the
primary and part of that money went to
the DNC but part of it went right to the
Hillary Clinton campaign as we know they
only scheduled what was it
twelve ten or twelve debates at the
worst possible times on the worst
possible nights to protect Hillary and
to save her from and god forbid she
could hold her own but they sort of felt
that they had to protect her from
debating Bernie or Martin O'Malley or
whatever uh and then with the
super-delegates that she had there were
over 400 DNC super-delegates who pledged
for Hillary Clinton support her at the
convention vote for the event before she
had even declared as president so it was
totally outrageous and we only found out
about we by the way Bernie said that I
said it I believed it we only found out
the evidence when the russians hacked
into the DNC emails John Podesta Z mails
do you so I've said before and I wonder
if you agree I don't necessarily think I
mean certainly this what the DNC did for
me is not a legal issue and even not
being an unbiased arbiter of the primary
is not objectively wrong to me as long
as you're transparent about it the
problem I have is posturing as an
unbiased arbiter of the primary and not
being one if everybody knew the DNC
picks someone early on if we all know
that that's a different story what do
you think absolutely and by the way
debbie Wasserman Schultz who was the
chair at the time well I mean she lived
she said that they were not they
not tilted toward Hillary but they did
and you're right Dave it's not illegal
what they did
I think it's undemocratic I took wrong
you know the whole Iowa I said at the
time that the Republican Party operated
more as a democracy in the primary than
the Democratic Party did in terms of the
process right they don't have very few
super-delegates and they have to follow
what the states how this notice of the
states go so yeah the DNC just lied to
the American people and to the
Democratic Party pretending to be
neutral when in fact they were just an
arm of the Clinton campaign
you mentioned Russia and I'm very
curious myself as someone who supported
Bernie Sanders in the primary but
believes what the evidence seems to be
pointing to when it comes to Russia I
have some concern about a contingent of
Bernie supporters who seem to be
rejecting everything we learn about
Russia because they feel in some way it
devalues Bernie's strength and props up
or makes Hillary seem like a better
candidate I think the idea being were it
not for Russia
maybe Hillary would have won which I
think were so far beyond at this point
can you give me an assessment as a
Bernie supporter of sort of what where
you see the Russia investigation at this
point
well first of all I think I don't know I
don't know any Bernie people who believe
that if they do they're dead before we
do some emails afterwards yeah okay but
you know what if they do they're dead
wrong they are as wrong as Donald Trump
is when he refuses to accept the fact of
absolute certain Russian attempts to
interfere in this election because he's
it devalues his election right and so
that's why that's why he's so much
against his mother and investigation he
again he thinks it undermines his win
look I'll tell you where I think the
Russian investigation is right now and I
think this is where Donald Trump is
totally clueless this is real it is
serious
it's a criminal investigation on the
part of this administers apartment on
the President of the United States he is
being investigated for at least two
things possible collusion with the
Russians we don't know for sure yet and
possible obstruction obstruction of
justice which i think is pretty evident
in the firing of James Comey and now
maybe the firing of the Andy McCabe and
the other thing we know is Mulder is a
serious man he is he's got a an
incredibly gifted team of prosecutors
and experienced team of prosecutors with
him and this investigation no matter
what what Donald Trump says is going to
end when robert muller says it's over
when he finishes his investigation and
then we'll see his final report it's not
going to end before unless Donald Trump
were to fire robert muller or try to
have him fired which i think would be
that as Lindsey Graham said a
constitutional crisis yeah I don't
disagree in the last couple of minutes
we have I'm curious about you know as a
talk radio veteran we've seen for a very
long period of time that the right does
better on broadcast talk radio not
talking about on line not talking about
any platform but broadcast talk radio I
have some ideas as to why that is what
what do you think has led to this
longtime domination of the talk radio
airwaves by the right you're kind enough
to mention my latest book which is from
the left life in the crossfire I
actually wrote an earlier book called
toxic Park where a few years ago where I
looked at this I think there's several
factors and you and I have both
struggled against them right I should
say you and I both survived and thrived
right back right one is the medium of
talk radio lit two angry old angry white
men who get their fix and that's all
they want and they're replenished by
that we're those of us progressives I
think are more open-minded I like to
hear different points of view and
swiffer us you know switch around the
dial try different people the red
Republicans never do that
secondly ownership ownership ownership
yep Serbs were very smart they went out
they bought up the networks they bought
up the stations they recruited talent
they trained the talent they put their
money into that talent and they kept
progressives off the air on many many
terrestrial stations the numbers are
overwhelming at one time there were 2000
news talk stations in the country and
maximum a hundred progressive talk radio
stations so you can't compete if they
won't let you on the air and the owners
won't let progressive voices on the air
so it's it's online and it's the
internet and it's free speech TV where I
think we are really still able to make a
difference and have our voices be heard
yeah I would I would even add to that
that structurally some right-wing
arguments on issues just lend themselves
to 30 60 and 120 second sound bites
right all abortion is murder that's
super simple the position on the Left
isn't just the opposite it's well it's
more complicated than that and you have
to sort of determine up to which point
in a Preda right the by their very
structure some of these right-wing
positions are just better for talk radio
yeah absolutely
or that Barack Obama's gonna take away
all your guns sure okay so then you get
into what is sensible gun safety
measures and you know you lose the the
extremists if you will the book is from
the left a life in the crossfire we've
been speaking with the book's author and
host of the bill press show bill press
thank you so much for talking to me
today
hey David great to join you I'm a big
fan thank you appreciate it